people don't understand antidepressant
withdrawal they know opiate withdrawal
and it does not feel like a normal
withdrawal it's not like a hangover or a
painkiller withdrawal it's just like
being put in a horror movie I literally
locked myself in my apartment and just
waited it out thinking I was nuts there
was intense intense mood swings rage
really really severe rage like
destructive rage [ __ ] it was like two
and a half years like that could have
been my parents lives like my dad in a
hospital actively being tortured from
the side effects my mom bringing him
food every day from medications he just
needed to be taken off of
[Music]
I'm pissed off about it
[Music]
hey folks I thought advertising for
schwank grills was a good idea for this
specific episode because of the topics
we cover psych Med withdrawal and how I
really only survived through that
without more misery because of the lion
diet the all meat diet I'm on because of
the diet I have tried basically every
Meat Company and grill out there at
least in North America and I can
personally vouch for how amazing the
schwank grills specifically are I own
one and it has produced some of the best
tasting steaks I've had right now
schwaint grills has an amazing discount
the biggest discount I've ever seen them
do and they say they've ever done with
255 off when you use code mp255 at
checkout their Black Friday deal was
supposed to end November 30th but for my
listeners only it has been extended to
December 5th with code mp255 typical
grills reach a temperature of around 600
Degrees schwenk grills reach 1500
degrees which is what you get when you
go to high-end stakehouses like Morton's
the grills are also portable so you can
take them on the road camping or to any
place Outdoors where you need to cook a
steak you never know when you're going
to need a steak for better steak and
less time and 255 dollars off just go to
schwankgrills.com and use code mp255
until December 5th only this is
seriously the biggest sale they've had
so if you are ever considering buying
one of these bougie 1500 degree grills
this is the time mp255 and
schwaintgrills.com
[Music]
I wanted to have you on my podcast
because I think you went through a
similar experience
that I went through which was awful I
have your book here
may cause side effects so before we get
into this
um can you give me a brief background
about who you are and what it is you do
sure uh so I'm my name is Brook seem I'm
sort of I guess most known as a chef I
won the Food Network show Chopped a
couple years ago so that's where a lot
of people normally know me from I
suppose but really the work that I
mostly focus on now is awareness around
antidepressant withdrawal especially
when it comes to medicating children and
then having them be on it for really
long periods of time so my book is about
the year I spent in withdrawal after I
was pulled off these drugs too quickly
by a doctor who didn't have any
education on the subject and this is
this is the first book it's Memoir that
exists like this on the subject and I
just really hope that it can help
patients feel less alone and less crazy
because what they're going through is a
very real thing and also doctors really
needed to help identify symptoms to
avoid misdiagnosis to be able to just
have a better understanding of what it
can be like to be in withdrawal for
people who are experiencing this
okay great so let's start with some
background information then sure um do
you mind talking about what you were
taking and how long you were taking it
sure so I was medicated when I was about
15 years old my father had suddenly
passed away and I was put on we tried a
few antidepressants before we landed on
a combination of Wellbutrin XL and
Effexor XR
those were the really the only two
antidepressants and psychiatric drugs I
stayed on for my entire experience with
this which is pretty rare a lot of
people end up getting shuffled around
but I also collected about four or five
other drugs that ultimately were used to
treat side effects caused by the
antidepressants we didn't really know
that at the time no one had put two and
two together and said you know maybe the
fact that your hair is falling out and
you can't keep any food down isn't it is
a side effect of these drugs instead we
thought they were separate issues so all
in all I ended up on a cocktail of about
usually between six sometimes seven
drugs depending on what was going on at
the time uh for 15 years it was never
questioned by any of the doctors I saw
in multiple different states I lived in
three different states for those 15
years they were pretty much refilled
without question and it wasn't until I
suddenly had the light bulb moment that
I hadn't had an unmedicated moment as an
adult and that I was still actively
suicidal and depressed that maybe this
wasn't working and that's when I decided
to get off the drugs
okay wow
um how old are you now I'm 36 now so
most of this went down when I turned 30
so that you know Big Year
yeah okay so how fast were you taken off
of medications I was taken off Effexor
cold turkey I a time I was on 37.5
milligrams of it which is the smallest
dose you can get on the market so this
was also 2016. the you know literature
and research on it on the topic was was
scant basically non-existent so the
doctor at the time she said well I can't
prescribe you a lower dose we can't get
that from the pharmaceutical companies
so just stop taking it and see what
happens and she she said I might feel
like I had the flu for a few days or
yeah you know but basically just kind of
a load of uh very nice things that
sounded nice but didn't end up being
true and so I was pulled off that right
away and I started experiencing pretty
severe symptoms within about three or
four days and they only escalated over
the next few months and then I stayed on
the Wellbutrin during that time and then
later I was pulled I took I got stopped
cold turkey as well
okay yeah so when I was on a ciprolux so
I started taking cyphilax I was in Gray
it was the summer of grade five when I
was extremely depressed and so I so
young so early it's so early yeah and I
stopped taking it cold turkey when I was
20 I can't it was 2015. so at 23. yeah
yeah so about the same length of time
ish
10 years at least it sounds like right
yeah and and I was on a lot I was on the
highest dose that you could like safely
I was actually on a higher dose I
remember I tried to get a prescription
at one point when I changed provinces in
Canada and they were like oh we can't
fill this like what yeah you can't fill
it I've been on this I need this right
because otherwise I'm like unbelievably
depressed but anyway
um can you describe what your
antidepressant withdrawal looked like
what symptoms did you have and how fast
did that start so most of mine most of
my serious very like acute symptoms came
from the effects are more than the
Wellbutrin for me personally Effexor has
a shorter Half-Life so it leaves the
body faster and creates more intense
symptoms
um the very first
notable symptom I mean I kind of felt
off I you know if you've ever missed a
dose of these drugs like I used to feel
like oh I had just taken like four shots
of espresso you know my heart would race
and I would feel kind of shaky so I I
anticipated that you know if I'd
accidentally forgotten to take it or you
know the pharmacy was closed or
something uh but then what happened is
one day I was I was living in New York
City at the time and I was walking on
Park Avenue and it had just started to
rain it was about Dusk and all of a
sudden like in one moment all of my
senses intensified like I saw the light
bulb
like come into focus and all the lights
from the taxis coming at me went from
round orbs into really sharp stars and
everything got super loud and then my
skin started really hurting with the
rain the rain was coming down and it
felt like bullets on my skin like little
BB gun bullets and I was just so
overwhelmed by this sensory feeling and
that's the first time I realized that
something something big is about to
happen to me and these drugs were doing
a lot more than just you know keeping my
depression at Bay which is what I
assumed was the only effect that they
were having I realized in that moment
that they were having an effect on my
entire physical system
and that in some ways is actually kind
of cool because I was like oh my God
it's like I've just woken up like what
else what else is there but then the
psychological side effects set in for me
and those were just the horrific ones I
mean the for me the worst part was
violent intrusive thoughts that just
went on for months and it's just you
know
it's a little difficult to explain but
it's kind of like this this awareness
that you have the ability to hurt
yourself or others at any moment and
then you can kind of see in your mind's
eye what you might do and if you'd never
experienced that before you
I thought it was absolutely crazy like
obviously I needed to be on psychiatric
medications because this is who I am on
the inside that's that's what I thought
but I was too terrified to tell my
psychiatrist about it because I thought
she would put me on an involuntary hold
so I just ended up like I literally
locked myself in my apartment and just
you know waited it out thinking I was
nuts and um that was the hardest one for
me to deal with mentally but then there
was you know the intense mood swings you
know
intense intense mood swings rage really
really severe rage like destructive rage
I stopped sleeping
um I didn't have Academia to I don't
think like if I did it was more in just
like a general pacing kind of antsiness
that I associated with just so many
changes but you know I know a little bit
about what you've described in your
anesthesia situation like I didn't feel
like that and I just feel like my God I
was so lucky not to have to have gone
through that
I mean I was yeah well after seeing what
happened to my dad so so for me I
stopped taking them cold turkey too and
Rich and um I'd been on I'd been off and
on Wellbutrin
for for a while but I actually I ended
up having a seizure on Wellbutrin so I'd
stop taking that when I was 21. I was on
they like increased the dose to try and
get a hold of the like depression and
get the depression symptoms under
control and then I had a seizure so we
got rid of that one which I don't I
think I just felt better getting rid of
that one but um the ciprolux I felt
pretty good like I got my depression
under control with dietary changes I was
like well don't eat this thing anymore
stop taking that and then I felt pretty
good for about a week and then
and like good like oh wow I can feel I'm
not sedated like things are great and
then
it was really for me at like a two-week
period where I went and it it almost
went from like normal to suddenly
horrifying in like
like a moment
yeah it was a day and I think it
coincided like um for me I was trying to
reintroduce more like carbier Foods so I
tried to introduce a food and we had
kind of an autoimmune response and then
that combined with the antidepressant
withdrawal and I hallucinated like I
went out it was the same thing it was
like things are a little too real and
they're a little too close and sounds
are too loud and like lights hurt like
and I'd always had kind of an aversion
to fluorescent lights which might have
been yeah me too hard of being on drugs
yeah
um everything was too bright and too
loud and too dark and like scary and um
and I was like my heart was beating
faster than it should and I was like I
think I like am I panicking am I having
a panic attack like what's going on here
and I ended up hallucinating like my
brother into kind of this demon face
looked at me and I was like I looked at
him I was like went into my apartment
and the same kind of thing turned on all
the lights closed the door and was like
okay yeah maybe I live here for the next
while yeah yeah
yeah that's yeah was it like um
was it like a
that's the best way to describe it was
it like a mind's eye hallucination or
was it like
if you had like his face was replaced in
your visual field
I mean it didn't like I knew I was
hallucinating obviously but my he turned
around and it it had this horrifying
like Teeth I think teeth like demon face
on my brother like so he turned into a
little demon looked at me and I was like
okay I've stopped taking all like kind
of similar I've stopped taking all my
medication and now I'm [ __ ] crazy
right and but then also part of me was
like no I felt so good like I know there
was a period of time where I could feel
good so
I had antidepressant withdrawal for two
and a half years
um
and
and it kind of went like up and down and
up and down and then and I just knew you
know I think I'm pretty sure I'm not
depressed like that I just need to to
wait and at the time actually how long
did it take you to figure out that you
were an antidepressant withdrawal
I don't even know that you were in
withdrawal yeah it didn't take me very
long uh I I think like after maybe the
first you know severe violent thought
episode
um a couple things happened one I had
talked to a psychologist who was a
friend a family friend who lived in a
different state so she couldn't commit
me so I was like okay I'll talk to her
um and she
she kind of helped me understand that
one that she said crazy people don't
know they're crazy so she basically made
me aware of that's good yeah the fact
that since I was aware of it then that
that is an important part in in the
process of making sure you're not
actually going to act on any of these
thoughts was still terrifying but at
least it like calmed me down from
thinking that oh God I'm gonna do
something terrible
um and then she you know kind of
indicated that it was about withdrawal
but she didn't know too too much about
the subject either
it really wasn't until I then just got
on the internet and I started searching
and there was there was almost no
literature at the time but there were a
couple of like Rogue websites with other
people explaining the same uh the same
things
that made me think okay
I'm having I'm having a reaction to
getting off these drugs it's clearly
antidepressant withdrawal I didn't know
it was a thing I thought it was really
rare I thought I was just like in a
really really rare Camp of people yeah
and it's you know now I know that that's
not the case that this is much much more
common than I ever thought in that that
we ever thought at the time but it did
make me feel like okay at least this is
a
anecdotally documented thing that I'm
not the only one
I didn't know I would last though I
thought it would go away a lot faster
than it did
that's for sure yeah how long did it how
long did it take for you for the acute
symptoms uh the acute symptoms were
about a year and at about a year is when
I started to say okay like I don't know
how long because it's you know the
windows and waves you're kind of going
up and down at least that's how it was
for me and so about after about a year a
year I felt confident that if I had a
bad stretch
I was going to come out of it so that's
for me when I started to make the mental
shift that okay this is not a forever
thing I don't know how long it'll last
but I be I started to you know just
embrace it if I guess if you can and
find some radical acceptance for the
process and the more I did that actually
the more things lessened and you know by
about two years I was like quite
confident that I was through it
I didn't know that it was I'm so pissed
off about this entire thing I didn't
know it was Auntie with depressant
withdrawal because I was doing these
diet so I've got a arthritis and I was
doing these diet tests and I was
reacting quite badly to like certain
carbier foods that were giving me
arthritis and autoimmune flaps and that
coincided with how severe the
antidepressant withdrawal was for me so
I was attributing the withdrawal to food
reintroductions just combined with the
flare-ups and arthritis yeah right so
for the first two and a half years
I literally just thought I had extremely
severe reactions to food yeah I did like
didn't know it was antidepressant
withdrawal I think because it took two
weeks to hit and then when it hit it was
when I reintroduced a food that gave me
an autoimmune response and it was like
after that I just couldn't like couldn't
get things under control and it was
crazy I was like having hallucinations
periodically like terrifying it didn't
occur to me that it was antidepressant
withdrawal
until Dad so he stopped taking the
antidepressants what's the order who
went first you or him I went first okay
so I went first I stopped taking them
December 2015 about three months after I
started a really low carb diet and got
my autoimmune we're going to do this at
the same time
yeah
yeah when did when was yours um I
started in like March of 2016.
yeah okay so that was that was December
2015.
um
Dad
stopped around the same time it was
later maybe February and
um I mean neither of us
even though he's a psychologist
he didn't know about the antidepressant
like people don't understand
antidepressant withdrawal they know
opiate withdrawal they're like okay
people can get addicted to opiates they
get like you can't stop taking those
suddenly you have to wean off it can be
unpleasant like extremely unpleasant it
can
depending on what you're on and how long
you've been on it and what dose and all
that but they do not know about
antidepressant withdrawal and it does
not feel like a normal withdrawal it's
not like a hangover or a painkiller
withdrawal it's just like being put in a
horror movie this episode is brought to
you by better fed beef better fed beef
is a direct to Consumer beef company
that specializes in certified Anya beef
you guys have probably heard me talk
about better fed I do that because
that's basically the only meat I eat now
unless I run out of them and then I eat
lamb and I honestly I kind of hate lamb
I eat lamb for a long time I never
really want to eat lamb again this beef
on the other hand is like wagyu except
they actually treat the cows really well
that's the other thing that makes these
guys different the cows are humanely
raised on Midwestern Family Farms the
offer I have for better fed is insanely
good you can get 25 off your order when
you go to betterfedbeef.com and use code
MP that's better fedbeef.com and use
code MP for a whopping 25 off your order
normally that kind of percentage off
doesn't happen in the meat world and in
a world where big business is taken over
and the gates family is buying up
Farmland like nobody's business it's
important to support Family Farms like
better fed beef you never know if we're
going to be eating crickets eventually
I'm certainly not but I'm supporting
these types of farms also because of the
craft butchering process they use the
whole animal which is cool so you get
cuts that are typically hard to find
like oxtail liver beef tongue and bone
marrow their bone marrow is to die for
as well as the usual favors like rib
eyes and New York strips and ribs did I
mention ribs their ribs are very good
too if you like good beef then you
should try better fed beef you can go to
butterfedbeef.com and use code MP for 25
off I've heard it's similar to benzo
withdrawal
um I've never it's been on benzos
so so this was what this is what
happened with us so antidepressant
withdrawal was one thing I was on
Lorazepam a little bit off and on thank
goodness I didn't take any
benzodiazepine long term that seems
worse so whatever antidepressant
withdrawal which was like it was the
worst thing I've ever experienced
um
and then I saw my dad so he went he
basically stopped taking antidepressants
and then
didn't feel good like neither of us felt
good we were trying to get it under
control with diet and my mom got cancer
and he started taking a benzodiazepine
but I think the reason he started taking
it this was through his doctor of course
was because he was an antidepressant
withdrawal and so he was like he was
like I'm suicidal I'm having these
thoughts I can't sleep he couldn't sleep
at all and his doctor was like whoa
here's Klonopin
and that was a bad idea that was a bad
idea and I've done a bunch of research
into this there's this doctor named
David Healy who's pretty knowledgeable
about yeah the dangers
um of drugs and like medicating somebody
in antidepressant withdrawal with a
benzodiazepine just like
destroys them so he was on that for a
while and then getting off of that the
withdrawal that caused almost killed him
that's when the akathisia popped up and
that is that's everything antidepressant
withdrawal is plus the absolute
inability to stop moving
like how is this something that exists
that doctors aren't screaming about it's
so unacceptable
I
I don't know I wish I had a better
answer I mean I it's just it's baffling
I
um I I especially
I don't know I think that part of what's
Happening Now is we're getting into a
period of time where people have been on
these drugs for significant portions of
their life and because there's not a
single long-term study for any of this
stuff right most most drug studies are
like 12 weeks and you know that's where
all the that's where all the nice
sounding data comes from right is from
these 12-week studies and so because
there's absolutely not a single study on
long-term use or pulling people off like
I think they just haven't seen it and
then so many of the signs and symptoms
mimic other psychiatric disorders I mean
when I was in withdrawal I could have
been diagnosed with bipolar
schizophrenia or a paranoid disorder a
paranoid disorder easily right and I
think that's what happens to most people
that's that's how they get like so many
different drugs just layered on top of
them and whatnot but I think there's
also just been a huge failure in the
system to I mean Psychiatry has been
Rife with not listening to patients
since it's Inception right and you know
I don't you can't fully blame Psychiatry
and psychiatrists is the whole when most
people are getting their antidepressants
from GPS
like that's what I did I got mine from a
GPA for eight years and so
they're they're General Practitioners
it's right there in the name they're not
they're not experts on this stuff so
it's just it's just and then it makes so
much money so it's just it's such a
terrible like Perfect Storm of events of
why people are now so screwed
um or why some people are now so screwed
on these things I would say like
and I don't want to freak people out but
this like from just because I was so
entrenched in this for first it was me
and I didn't know what it was right it
actually I remember I had this moment
when Dad kept getting misdiagnosed with
like bipolar schizophrenia I was like
he's not schizophrenic he's reacting to
the med like something's going on with
the Klonopin like he's not schizophrenic
you morons yeah this is ridiculous
they're like well what do you know like
little blonde girl right it's like also
like how do you move this is
schizophrenia right like give me a blood
test you can't measure it in the same
way so it's just it's just like based on
yeah
so annoying so bothersome
um
yeah I'm I don't know I think probably
awareness is just the right way to go I
had somebody message me like I get
messages
constantly from people who are really
really suffering you probably do now
yeah you come out with a book but um
somebody yesterday was like
you know
I'm I'm suicidal my I'm suicidal with
depression
and then you can do the one way where
it's like oh go talk to your doctor
except that never works because then
you're suicidal with depression and
better put that person on a
benzodiazepine antidepressant
antipsychotic something to calm them
down and uh so it's just like well how
long have you been taken the meds two
years it's like okay were you suicidal
before you started the meds
no I was just depressed okay suicidality
is a lot worse than than being depressed
I was like so anyway just like sent some
information but finding a doctor that
knows about this stuff is like nearly
impossible do you have do you have
recommendations for people who are
currently on medications about like
how to do this other than like weaning
down and locking yourself in a room like
there's got to be something there's got
to be resources I mean there are
resources but they're certainly not
perfect and they are they're very much
in their infancy and so it's kind of one
of those things where you know I'm happy
to kind of let people know what the
latest stuff is but at the end of the
day I think what antidepressant
withdrawal and depression and all of
this stuff really asks you to do is to
go Inward and find what works for you I
mean you know all about that right with
the lion diet right like it might not
work for everyone but it's been a
lifesaver for you so like
that the amount of inner resilience and
inner gumption you have to have in order
to make that sort of choice for yourself
despite what other people say is huge
and that's what I think that's in a lot
of ways what healthy mental health is
it's figuring out what each individual
needs so you know for example like the
the the the main Theory right now with
with antidepressant withdrawal and how
to avoid it or how to get off these
drugs safely is something called
hyperbolic tapering it's basically a
dose reduction method it ends up looking
like a hyperbolic curve so one that
starts off very Steep and ends up and
ends up flatter
because you make percentages of cuts for
each drug so say you're on 100
milligrams of something you cut it by 10
oh you cut it by 10 so you go down to 90
milligrams and then assuming you're
doing okay you cut that another 10 so 10
of 90 milligrams is 9 grams so now
you're down to 81 and so on and so forth
until the doses get smaller and smaller
and the reason why this tends to be more
successful in the early research they've
done is just because it allows the brain
and body to uh basically stabilize at an
easier rate instead of having to make
these big jumps in between the typical
pharmaceutical doses
um this isn't perfect there are still
people who struggle on these you know
and have serious symptoms even while
doing hyperbolic tapering but it's but
it's a start so I would say you know
Google that read the research on that
um you know also uh Latin America is an
amazing resource so is anatomy anatomy
of an epidemic by Robert woodenker
there's just a lot of information there
that I think patients can help educate
themselves and then go take them to
their doctor take the information to
their doctor and say like because you
still need a doctor to like you know
fill your prescriptions and help you go
down so
you know the best course of action is
going to be a partnership if you have a
Doctor Who's completely dismissive of
your of one what you want for yourself
and also you know
information continuing education on how
you can hopefully get through this as
best as possible if you've got a Doctor
Who's fighting that it's time to find a
new doctor like it's time to step up and
take some agency and say no we're not
doing this together and you know go off
and find a new one
um
so and that's honestly that's kind of it
at this point other than just so sad but
other than other than just you know
reading the room reading anecdotes a
little bit we've seen a lot more
mainstream articles about antidepressant
withdrawal and you know New York Times
and the New York or New York Post and
all of these very like
traditionally you know medication all
the time people so I'm glad to see that
that means that the shift is changing or
I mean there's a there's a change oh God
glad to see that there's you know a
change in the narrative there
um there's also a lot more research
being done in Europe in the UK than
there is here in the US so sometimes you
have to go outside of the US
and uh but yeah beyond that I mean it's
it's it's it's a
dark world out there but it's like I
don't know for me it was the best
decision I ever made to get off these
drugs like yes it's very awesome me too
it's a scary thing and I you know on the
one hand I want people to be really
aware of what this what can happen so
they're they don't think that they are
schizophrenic suddenly right yeah and
you know yes it can be really really
difficult but it is the single best
thing I've ever done my done for myself
even though it was the hardest thing
I've ever been through and I'm just my
life is so much better I'm so glad I did
it
yeah yeah for sure this by no means
means don't do it you're stuck on this
forever it just means first of all cold
turkey is so dangerous and it's not even
just like
um it's not even just that the
withdrawal is sudden and much worse it's
also it can also trigger like secondary
things like Academia yeah in certain
people and not everybody gets that but
in certain people that can happen and
once you trigger something like that
going back on the medication doesn't
necessarily get rid of it so the cold
turkey thing can be very dangerous
especially if you've been on a high dose
for a long period of time but getting
off of them
yeah it's been it's I I was experiencing
a lot of side effects that I had been
attributing to my autoimmune disorder I
was just about to say my entire life I
was just about to say like how
interesting it is how all your other
issues at least for me like directly
connected back to this it's such a
systemic thing and we really think it's
a we think it's only about our emotions
and our feelings right and it's just not
it's completely systemic
yeah so you had can you talk to me about
what kind of like side effects you were
treating that you found out were just
attributed to the antidepressants yeah I
mean we don't have like I don't have
conclusive evidence that it was
contribute that it was con or that it
was you know um because of these drugs
but what I do know is that I didn't have
these issues before I went on the drugs
within a year I had all these problems
and then when I got off these drugs 15
years later all those problems
disappeared so I was like okay
um I don't know coincidence maybe uh but
the first thing is is I developed like
hypothyroidism and all the signs of
hypothyroidism so my hair was falling
out I like was getting crazy charlie
horses at night and then blood tests
actually showed that my thyroid function
was low and so that's when they started
giving me Synthroid which is a synthetic
hormone
I also developed something called
bioreflex disease this took a little
while to diagnose but it basically is
like it's like acid reflux but lower
down in your GI so your pancreas spits
up all this extra bile into your stomach
and then I would just get randomly
nauseous and like you know be walking
this walking to school and I'd throw up
on the sidewalk and it was just like oh
um yeah yeah I had something similar
okay I had I had something similar it
wasn't like
chronic like that it happened a couple
of times when I mixed so I was quite
like the antidepressants initially when
I was a kid and went on them I can
remember feeling relaxed and relief and
being like okay I can sleep right like
I'm not having intrusive thoughts and
and all this and I was already on immune
suppressants at that point when I went
on the antidepressants but um but my
depression was horrible the entire time
like it didn't make it go away and it
was more intrusive I would say the older
I got the higher that I just you know
went up on medication and up on
medication and then my depression got
worse and worse
um and I tried adding in 5-HTP which is
just it's like a herbal supplement
and I tried adding that in and I threw
up every morning for a week I was like
what taking a supplement this shouldn't
just cause you like half an hour after
the supplement on the way to school on
the Subways like up throw up in a
garbage can what is happening and it was
like oh there's too much serotonin
because of the 5-HTP like that's weird
but I was little so I was like you know
17 I was like well okay no 5 HTP
yeah so it was It was kind of similar I
just would randomly puke and so they put
me on like a really really heavy anti
that's fun and antacid for that yeah it
was so fun
um and then I was nauseous all the time
um then then like my skin got really bad
and so I ended up on a variety of like
stuff like either like touch recycling
which is antibiotic which is bizarre
eventually it was on Accutane like that
never really went away oh which yeah I
mean again like it's like nobody looked
at what I was taking and thought
combining this was a good idea
um and then I also had like constant
headaches and migraines so I was always
taking either migraine meds or a lot of
Advil for that
and I just like dealt with that for you
know again the same these same 15 years
but then when I started when I got off
the effexor and then later when I got up
to Wellbutrin I was like I was just like
I'm on a roll at this point we're just
gonna get off of everything and see what
happens so I got off this in the
Synthroid and um the sucralfate which
was for the bile reflux disease neither
one of those things came back and my
thyroid levels are totally normal now
um
and then and then the last issue that is
still kind of the thing is just that
like gut health has been an absolute
nightmare to get back and I mean again
when you look at this these drugs have a
huge impact on your gut plus I mean I
was on antibiotics for acne at some
point right that'll that'll kill your
gut and so so many years I think of that
damage has made it pretty challenging to
get my gut back on track like it's doing
better now with a lot of
a lot of very expensive like medical
help and supplements and testing and all
that but
um and kimchi but yeah that's it I mean
oh that's it and then the other thing
too though it's really interesting and
I'm so fascinated about the audio
autoimmune stuff and the trigger because
I actually in withdrawal developed
something called nodular vasculitis
which is an autoimmune response
to it's like a like inflamed blood
vessels so I had all these weird little
bumps all over my skin and like patchy
discoloration that they thought was
lupus but that's hard to diagnose and
then when they actually did a sample of
it it was just my blood vessels were all
so inflamed that they like puffed up and
that's a autoimmune response associated
with tuberculosis of all things as a
stress response from getting off these
drugs
okay so I've been really interested
um
and this is all like there isn't any
this isn't completely new right people
didn't even know antidepressants cause
withdrawal
um I've wondered from watching what
happened to my dad which was just like
the worst I thought my antidepressant
withdrawal was bad and then I watched
him and that experience was worse than
like my auntie was so bad
um
or was I going with that okay but it
looks like a lot of the symptoms that
you get from antidepressant withdrawal
or benzodiazepine withdrawal mimic like
nerve damage right like how can you have
lights hurt and sounds I still have
issues with like certain sounds
yeah normal people I don't think have
like hey that sound hurts sounds aren't
supposed to hurt and like and like you
said it actually hurts like I can't
explain how it hurts but somehow it's
like it's not just uncomfortable it's
not just like oh like let me go to
another room it like like scratches your
brain a little yeah and I feel like in
my bones in a weird way yeah yeah
yeah oh wow I mean I'm not sure other
than I mean obviously we don't know we
don't even really know how
antidepressants works so we sure as hell
don't know how and I did depressant
withdrawal works but like I just I just
think they they just must have such an
intense effect on you know the
neurobiology and
your whole system and
I mean like what is it 90 of our of
Serotonin is created in the gut these
are ssris so they are selective
serotonin reuptake Inhibitors so they're
while also theoretically
theoretically right like marketed as
selective serotonin reuptake Inhibitors
I don't think they actually know how
they work no they don't like they have
theories yet
but they definitely don't act on just
one thing because like no such a complex
system even if something does act on one
thing your entire body has to react and
readjust right
so
I mean on my my completely unscientific
theory is that you know yes these
they they blunt emotional pain they
blunt they numb the edges of both good
and bad experience they also numbed all
of my physical experience as well and
that's what I was kind of describing
when that first moment when it was like
the cellophane was lifted off my body
for the first time and all my senses and
nerves were like
lit up either someone really fun ways
like color got brighter like literally
oh my God my color got yeah color got
brighter for me too I was like that's
what red looks like yeah
and if you've been on these since you
were a kid like you just don't have any
frame of preference for what red looks
like
and so that was great I like that my
world is more colorful now but
then there was the actual like physical
pain like I couldn't wear clothes I
struggled to wear clothes because it
just felt like scratchy daggers from the
fibers
but who knew that that was going to be
connected I didn't we told them yeah
still not really interesting
yeah no I had the same thing I wore
rayon for a really long time when I was
in like a cute me too my rounds nice and
soft yeah yeah it's like so strange a
few times if I got this one's gotta go
who can't wear it
wow around like this
that's so awful that's so awful and I
I'm sure there's so many people like I
can remember when I was on them and I I
took them religiously at night
for like over a decade
um when I was in university I got quite
a bit sicker I got more mentally ill my
diet also just went to complete [ __ ] I
was drinking all the time and there were
there was a day or two like one time I
got switched from ciprolax which is an
SSRI and I was like this is not working
like I'm on fire like some not this
isn't working I need something else I
need more and I got put on an snri
and I can't remember what the snri was
called because I took it for two days
and they just added it in and I was like
oh I just wanted to like just punch
holes in walls all the time I was like
that's gotta go that didn't work never
mind I'll just go back to what I'm doing
um but no I'm incredibly grateful that I
stopped taking them yeah well even who
knows what that was right that could
have been withdrawal effects that you
started to experience and then they put
an snri in there but you were still
experiencing withdrawal from the SSRI
oh for sure who knows what's what right
happens yeah
oh it's crazy and I'm also grateful that
I avoided
like like when I started experiencing
antidepressant withdrawal this is before
Dad stopped taking his I went out for
dinner with my mom and dad
and they're just like how do you feel
and I just like bawled and I'm not like
I don't I'm not a crier
I just got it was just like I was in the
middle of a horror movie it was
terrifying and I just like bawled and I
sat down and I was like trying to you
know order my food and make sure that it
didn't have any these foods that were
like making the autoimmune symptoms
worse and I was just like teary and
weepy and my parents were like whoa yeah
maybe you should start taking those
again like this doesn't look good and I
was just like absolutely not I am never
taking anything again like and I didn't
even know I think a couple years in I
realized
when even when I started taking like
okay I'd take an antihistamine I can't
take antihistamines I get like severe
side effects from antihistamines I can't
take anything anymore without getting
extreme side effects Tylenol sometimes
is okay that's about it have you heard
of the Sip 450 genes at 450 tests
I feel like this might be highly
relevant to you and your family
oh
um cypd is that a peptide uh no
um so I mean my knowledge on it is like
you know sort of limited obviously
because I'm not I'm not a genetic oh
interesting but so the civ450 test and
and and what they do is it's it's
designed or what they do is it's
primarily using for cancer at this point
right now so they test you for these
Gene variants because it helps dictate
whether or not you're able to metabolize
drugs
and so but there's research from a
researcher named Sama eichel and Bloom
shaveled I think she's based out of um
New Mexico she's testing this particular
these genes and these Gene variants Gene
variants against psychoactive drugs
because what is starting to come up a
little bit is you have all of these
instances of you know severe violence
that can happen when people start taking
these drugs yeah the question is why
right and so her theory is that
um
is that it has to do with these genes
and that if you have what like what does
she say she says there's an association
between prescription drugs most notably
antidepressants and other psychoactive
medication having variant
alleles alleles for sale alleles for sip
450 genes and altered emotional states
of acts of violence so these particulars
that's cool yeah these particular
regimes seems to indicate okay you can't
metabolize these drugs or any drugs some
people apparently can't really
metabolize any of them which is why they
test them for cancer drugs
and it creates a literal toxic buildup
in the system oh my God and that's why
things go Haywire for certain
individuals so like
this I think it's so fascinating from
you know a violence standpoint but then
I don't you know I would be very
interested to know if like your your
sensitivity right if that is somehow
connected like is there just a literal
genetic inability to metabolize a lot of
these compounds
that's interesting okay something's got
to be going on because something has to
be going on because I'll do you know I
had to have surgery for my ankle
um this was after I got off all the
medications and
um I started taking Hydromorphone for
pain and ankle replacement surgery and I
ended up it was okay at the beginning
and then it was hives and then it was
throwing up and I was like okay well
can't take this anymore like within half
an hour of taking it throwing up I was
like okay what's that about and then
it's the same thing with like
antihistamines I get this horrible
crawling sensation everywhere and my dad
was the same way like anything he takes
like absolutely not we've realized
Tylenol is okay kind of and that's it
it's crazy maybe it's that I'll look
into that it's got to be some sort of
inability because it feels like I'm
having some sort of allergic reaction
yeah like a like in a very angry way
right well especially
worked and then it got worse over time
could indicate
it's not processing out
interesting wow well hopefully talking
about this stuff will make people aware
that they're not just you know
that these are serious and people don't
know how they work or how to get off of
them very easily yeah that being said
I've also seen people get off of them
without having nearly as many issues
yeah oh so have I I mean I think like
some of the research is about 50 that
it's roughly about half and half that
that half people get off of them have no
real issues at all and then the other
half about
of the people who have withdrawal
symptoms about half of those it's severe
but then so that's still a that's still
way too like one out of four and your
sound is Gonna Hurt yeah when there's so
many tens probably hundreds of millions
of people around the world on these
drugs like it's just way too too too
many people but it's certainly not a
guarantee
um
yeah it's a that's about right in my
anecdotal experience too about the
people like I've got a lot of friends
and people who say okay well you know I
want to get off my drugs like will you
will you coach me through it and I'm
just gonna like yeah well I'm not a
doctor but like I'll I'll help you make
sure you know give your shoulder to cry
on and tell you that you're not crazy
and from my anecdotal experience too
it's it's roughly about split half and
half as people who are having a pretty
hard time and people who are just like I
don't know I might be a little weepy but
like it's okay so
interesting
hmm yeah
so it's not everyone well that's good
did you notice
um an increase in food sensitivities
when you stopped taking them
or did you not really notice a diet roll
so for me Diet was like I mean of all
the problems I was having with food
seemed didn't even occur to me that that
could somehow be contributing at all
I've since found out because I've now
been kind of on this journey to figure
out why my gut's so screwed up that like
I I I've stopped eating both gluten and
dairy and have markers for the
sensitivities there and I yeah
everything's doing a lot better since
stopping that so you know God only knows
that I was doing that the whole time but
I don't know if it would have helped
withdrawal specifically
um
that I was I was like I was so kind of
far gone in a way that I wasn't really
in even in a place to like consider
whether or not I should go out get
myself some good you know
some good healthy organic broccoli
instead of just like yeah whatever was
in my cabinet
so I think I was lucky in in the way I
never considered stopping taking the
antidepressants I never was like this is
a problem and I want to stop them I was
like I'm going to be on these forever
and thank God I have these like that was
my opinion but then when I started
playing around with diet for the
arthritis and the skin issues and then
that started and then my depression went
away I was like what
that's associated and so I think I was I
probably avoided some symptoms by
cutting down because I I noticed for
sure when I reintroduced certain foods
that would cause the like hallucinations
and I just attributed it to the diet but
it was 100 because of the antidepressant
withdrawal and just flare-ups just like
it was like the um reaction my body was
having to certain foods was the same as
like sound hurting and light hurting
um
it was the same kind of thing but
miserable experience wouldn't recommend
it to anyone there are definitely ways
to get off of them where you don't just
stop taking them and then wonder what's
going on for two and a half years yeah
or even if you are you know going
through a tapering process and you're
being really diligent with it and you're
still having symptoms at least you know
why at least it's not this
I guess I'm crazy forever or depressed
forever type of thing like there's
yeah and it goes away people really need
to know that because when you're in it
it doesn't feel like it's going to go
away ever and that's that's part of the
really scary part is like whatever the
symptoms are it's like this is I'm crazy
and I'm going to be stuck like this
forever I had those thoughts but then I
was like there's a part of me that was
like nah people can't survive this crazy
I was like people like this state of
being Isn't survivable So I must be
damaged and if I'm damaged I should be
able to heal because like this is too
crazy to last exactly God I think that's
so important because
the whole narrative in mental health is
like okay this you know you've got this
bad thing so you have to manage or cope
with this bad thing but there's no focus
at all on our body's innate ability to
heal and how our body's always trying to
get back to homeostasis it's trying to
get back to like a natural happy healed
point for our own personal body so like
the brain is amazing it's plastic it's
malleable it can change it just needs
time and you have to
give it time and if you you've spent so
many years basically like literally
changing your brain chemistry through
these neurotropic drugs
like it's unreasonable to think that
like in my case I spent 15 years on
these drugs that I was going to be like
you know perky and normal after a week
it's just
we need more time
yeah and if you think about it like well
as if like if somebody was drinking and
they drank every day right then getting
off of alcohol is going it's going to be
messy right and you're not hungover for
a day or or two if you've been drinking
every day for 15 years right and these
drugs like they work every day it was
crazy to subject your brain to something
that saturates all your
neurotransmitters in something
constantly for for like a decade and a
half for you yeah and it gets stored in
your eye too so that's why it doesn't
just like
it stays in your body for longer periods
of time so it has to filter out and
takes different times for different
people
and then there's also there's like that
and I'm very curious to know how you
dealt with this because there's the
there's the psychological Fallout of it
all too like
like
I had not only created this whole
identity around this idea that I was
broken permanently and that there was
you know it was my brain that was the
problem it wasn't me so you know I was
going to be depressed not just who I was
I had spent so long in that space that I
had developed an identity around it and
so you know it's very convenient in some
ways I had an excuse for everything but
then once I got off all these drugs and
like started healing suddenly I was
completely I had no idea who I was I'd
been medicated since I was a kid since
my dad died right like there's you can't
use your 14 year old self as your frame
of reference for who you are as a 30
year old adult so then that process of
actually
almost like relearning who I was and
figuring out who I was as an adult while
also feeling incredibly stunted because
so much of what I like I feel like so
much my emotional development was
stunted when I was medicated I had that
it that's been brutal in a completely
different way just because it's like I
feel so behind and like
having to learn stuff that most people
learned in their 20s and it's just
it just makes me feel handicapped in a
way
I had that I had that for sure
um I didn't know what role and he just
antidepressants had played in the
development of my personality
all right so if you're on them I started
them I was either 11 or 12. I think I
was 12.
and um I had like a set personality on
them
and now it turns out after I started
taking them when I was 23 I'm 30. so
seven years not being on them I'm like
no I'm pretty much like I was
on them but much much less volatile and
much less emotional
so the emotional part of my personality
is like got wiped out and I think part
of that like that might even be a hyper
response to how I was because like so
now I'm in situations like this isn't
stressful at all like maybe I should be
feeling some stress that I'm not feeling
because everything was so stressful for
so long that now normal things that
should be stressful don't feel stressful
but anyway I I had that I had that for
sure and I had it like actively that I
was concerned about it so I stopped
taking them and I was like
am I a good person I remember I I had
that I was like am I a good person like
so yeah I think that's normal too and it
was good person I was in like my
emotions were all out of whack yeah like
am I feel like do I feel guilt it turns
out I do feel guilt but like there was a
period of time where I was like I'm not
sure if I feel guilt right it's like oh
no the guilt is there and then it's like
do I care about when you know when other
people are hurt
oh no no I still care but like that's
really scary to go through yep
especially if other people are involved
like I know it's wreaked havoc on my
personal relationships because I'm just
kind of like
like it's like they people look at me
like okay you should probably react this
way this is an appropriate way to react
in this situation and I'm just like
like sometimes I'm either completely
shut down or I'm just bawling and either
way it's like seems very inappropriate
to the other person involved and it's
just taken a long time to realize like
okay there's there's an actual learning
curve to this sort of uh emotional
reaction here that I am now having to
learn as a 30 year old adult not as you
know a teenager which is when a lot of
people learn this and um
I I only think it's now I mean it's been
six years since I've been off these
drugs that I'm starting to feel pretty
confident and okay like
what is who who am I versus what have I
had to learn and
walking that line has just been really
tricky
that's super interesting I totally
forgot that I went through that and but
I attributed it this was before I knew I
went through antidepressant withdrawal
so what I thought was
I started a diet diet helped my
autoimmune disorder and then I got
really sensitive to the foods I was
eating
for like a period of two and a half
years then I finally went on the
carnivore diet which is like geez just
get rid of all the variables yeah and
then about five months after that
the lingering anxiety went away did you
ever um
and what I didn't attribute it to
antidepressant withdrawal until my dad
was like obviously reacting to the drugs
he was on
um did you experience a period of like
elevated mood after you stopped taking
them after the down kind of like a mini
nipple Mania yeah or hypomania something
like that you know I didn't get it in
the sense that
um I didn't get it in a way that like
other people would have said oh she's
talking really fast or something seems
off but it was more just like and again
I don't know if this I think I I
definitely kind of over corrected but
then it is since come in a sense
normalized but
I just I kind of just had this like
really big burst of creativity and and
focus in the sense that you know again I
wasn't sleeping I went from sleeping
like 12 hours a night and taking a three
hour nap every day because that was how
the drugs worked with me to like okay
now I'm sleeping four or five hours I'm
like what am I gonna do with all this
extra time
um so I just suddenly had this urge to
paint and I would you know paint into
the night and then I was I was I knew I
was going to be on Chopped and I was
having a meltdown over that because I
was in withdrawal and I was like I'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] on TV and this is
gonna be bad so I just got obsessive
about flash cards and studying and so I
I really channeled that I did that you
did like for school that's so funny yeah
I was in um biomedical science and
University
I had a [ __ ] number of flash cards
that I had hand made I don't know how
many flash got I think I had 400 of them
like seriously to memorize you know
biology terms which is like it's a way
it works
yeah that's weird so I yeah I I don't
feel like because I channeled it so much
it felt very productive I don't know
what that might have looked like if I
was like didn't have a way to channel it
um but I definitely like
ah
it was just such a contrast between
being down and being and being up I mean
and like as even as I'm talking about it
you can hear how it's so easily been
given a bipolar diagnosis right using
terms down and up and you know those
sorts of things but um
it's just like when I felt good I felt
really good and I just thought maybe I
was done and I felt smart and productive
and clear and focused and then it would
just turn and then it would be awful for
days or weeks and just kind of never
knew how it was going to go so
it's just exhausting
that's weird
see yeah that's that's super strange I
wonder what that
I mean people don't know so there's not
even that much of a use of talking about
it but why would that why would that
happen like for instance I I was put on
oxycontin for my hip and ankle
replacement when I was 17. I took an
insane amount of painkiller I was in an
insane amount of pain for a whole year
and then I had withdrawal I could feel
it for about a year after that so it was
like acute for six weeks
and then I was like okay it's over but
it wasn't my brains like every six
months I was like oh I'm a bit better
for a couple years but it was kind of
linear it was like you know three weeks
of really bad and then three weeks of
kind of bad little bit of suicidality at
the end there and then and then better
and then six months better and
antidepressant withdrawal which is why I
correlated it with
the autoimmune reactions I was having
because I was definitely happening but
they went
crazy up and down like why would you
feel fine in the middle of withdrawal
for a while
and then be back and like hell so
strange
I don't know it's a really good question
I mean I would just kill for someone to
do some
very diligent brain scans
wow someone's going through this I just
I mean for all we know like
stuff is turning off and on I mean we
know that some of these um psychotropic
drugs they they decrease great they do
gray matter I think they they change
they change brain size they they act a
few parts of your brain I mean and then
the brain has to over correct in other
parts of the brain like take up and are
overactive and so I don't know maybe
it's just
like literally the brain kind of going
back and forth until it finally finds
balance but we don't we don't know we
don't have the research
armchair hypothesis here
yeah well it was wild when we went to so
we couldn't get any help in the Western
World to get Dad off of meds and and
like dad's super smart so he'd get into
the office and he'd like you know out
talk The person but he was have like he
wasn't able to stop moving
and and he knew it was the the drugs too
but going down on them made that worse
it was like this is bad it exists on the
drug and getting going lower makes it
worse I was like I think they all have
to go completely right and
and we tried to go everywhere I kept
calling you know hospitals and doctors
and being like okay this is my dad he's
having like an allergic reaction to the
medication he's on plus mixed with
withdrawal what would you do if we got
there and they'd be like well it sounds
like bipolar so we'd adjust his
medication and I was just like we called
52 places and I was like okay so we went
to Russia and they just got rid of the
drugs which was so dangerous and so
scary
um but he felt way better in like a
six-week period almost like it was bad
but you know he didn't die in an asylum
which was what was going to happen
and and now he's like you know it took
2019 it took like three years for him to
like recover from all that and now he's
on tour and he's totally fine and he's
not taking anything amazing right yeah
but like this stuff it kills people I I
wonder how many of the people walking
around the streets that you see talking
to themselves are on psychiatric
medications and have been missing doses
or going up and down or being switched
yep and that's not even their mental
disorder yeah yeah the uh Robert
Whitaker goes into that a bit in the
anatomy of an epidemic was one of the
hypotheses because the so many of the
bipolar drugs and the antipsychotics
like create major
uh brain changes over time that create
the Tremors and all sorts of things
I mean if they're getting okay hold off
and start stop and left right and Center
you know they okay so they create major
brain changes yeah so that that's why so
I started on that like the Russia topic
because when we went there they did
scans in my dad's brain and and they're
like oh he has brain changes from the
antidepressant use and I was like what
the [ __ ] like what are you doing you
know everything changes that can't be
good they didn't this they're speaking
in Russian like getting information
through a translator they're just like
yeah antidepressant cause brain changes
and I was like no that's not supposed to
happen yeah I was like is that because
then that would have happened to me it's
like that's right that's not supposed to
happen it's like yeah yeah it's
long-term high-dose antidepressant use
brain changes yeah oh brain changes
sounds bad yeah I mean I think if we
think of
I I think that there's such a spectrum
here right I think there there are you
know there are people who can get all
these drugs no problem
um no issues at all there are people
probably more like I think I'm probably
on the far end of the spectrum where
like I'm not sure I had actual brain
damage but I had really severe
withdrawal but then there are other
people who seem to have like actual like
brain damage that you could see in scans
and I don't know if I had that because I
you know was nowhere near that ability
to get a scan but
it's just it's it's like complex PTSD
right it's not just PTSD it's an actual
there's actual changes to the brain the
brain the organ has been harmed and it
makes sense that then you're having
these you know biological physical
symptoms that Cascade down the chain
yep pretty unacceptable so you have it's
I think you know this is gonna happen to
a lot in more and more people it's just
sorry go ahead no I just wanted to say
like
I just
I think that you and your dad
you saved a lot of lives by being going
public with what was going on and it was
pretty instrumental for this book to
happen actually because I remember when
you started doing all the updates for
your dad when he was in Russia and the
fact that that was happening that told
me I was like this is this is about to
be a really big deal because we have
someone here who's pretty high profile
going through this and this is going to
get a lot of people's attention and that
really told me that honestly they told
me that I wasn't that I wasn't nuts and
that the story really needed to be told
and it gave me a lot of motivation to
keep writing this book and get it out
there and so I just
like I think you guys
have helped a lot of people indirectly
and directly from sharing that
experience just thank you for that
ah
like not not gonna cry thank you thank
you I've been so angry I was so angry
like I saw my dad just get toward I got
tortured like hallucinating what the
[ __ ] is that I want to hallucinate
demons that's scary like other than
everything else but then what happened
to dad with akathisia and then
it was so bad it was every doctor we
went to and it was like him too being
like I'm done I'm done like I'm gonna
die I'm done and then I was there being
like
no absolutely [ __ ] not you're not
gonna die like this is a drug thing and
your brain can heal but like whoa did
his brain have to heal akathisia is a
terrifying thing and he doesn't have it
anymore so thank God for that but I was
like this is like I'm not gonna be able
to stop talking about this because this
almost killed my dad and like it didn't
almost kill him it almost left him to be
tortured every day from Psych Med
effects in an asylum that's where it
almost left him it almost left my mom
like
oh it got me but like
when he was hospitalized for a while
she was like bringing him food every day
I've got like a touch of just a touch of
PTSD from these like experiences but it
was like [ __ ] it was like two and a half
years like that could have been my
parents lives like my dad in a hospital
actively being tortured from the side
effects my mom bringing him food every
day from medications he just needed to
be taken off of
so anyway
I'm pissed off about it so that's why we
started yeah we started to talk about it
too it's like if there are other people
going through this they just need to
know that they have to wait they just
have to get through it and they're going
to be okay afterwards
and then to also incorporate like this
this needs to be enough up in the
Zeitgeist that when people are
considering starting these drugs they
need to know that this is a possibility
and not in just some like form that's
four pages long of tiny print and you
sign saying oh yeah I was informed of
the side effects like this needs to be a
serious conversation with your with
doctors before these medications are
started and especially for God's sake
for kids like these drugs still I was on
effexor and Wellbutrin like well they're
still not prescribed they're still not
approved for children
why like why was I put on them I off
label like it's just
it's just I think we are such a
fear-driven society in that especially
like with all the you know awful
suicides and everything that's happening
with kids that it's just terrifying
parents into trying to avoid
the hard stuff and to avoid looking at
their own role in their children's lives
and what's happening to the child I mean
you know I don't know what was going on
with you or in fifth grade but like
there had to have been something right
like I don't know if this came out of
blue or what and well I I I'd be curious
to know but I don't you know it's
obviously your story you don't have to
answer it I mean it's pretty comp like
if I could go back then I would you know
obviously now knowing what I know I
would say absolutely not but I mean I
was very depressed so I'd been I'd been
diagnosed with arthritis and I was on
two different immune suppressants in
grade two and so by grade five I was
like
I wasn't on anything other than two like
injectable immune suppressants like
Methotrexate and Enbrel they use
Methotrexate for cancer like it's an
intense drug but I was like I wasn't
sleeping I was having really Vivid
nightmares I was having suicidal
thoughts I was really angry like
punching walls angry I was just in grade
five and that was from like
honestly this is part of the reason I
talk about my diet all the time is I I
do think if I had even just gone
gluten-free and dairy free and gotten
rid of the processed foods
I think that would have lowered all of
those depressive symptoms but I can also
understand like
my parents my dad was also depressed at
the time like looking at their kid and
being like
you don't want them to hurt like a grade
five or grade six or whatever you don't
want them to hurt themselves and it's
like well they could take the medication
I'm taking it helps me that's what my
dad thought and it did help initially
which just makes everything confusing
it's like oh yeah Michaela's calmed down
but then it was like years went by and I
got like worse and worse and the
depression got worse and worse and
suicidal like impulses and violent
thoughts got worse
but if you think about it like I mean I
just can't imagine what
um the the stress the emotional stress
on a second grader
for all all of the physical stress and
you know those those really heavy drugs
and you know a young brain that can't
rationalize any of this stuff I mean
you know it's just the the
I think the fear how much is that the
fear and the depression seems like a
natural reaction to a pretty terrible
situation for what like a seven-year-old
who can't express themselves very well
and
you know obviously like I know I don't I
don't know how we would address that
with a young child
um
but I just you can't put them on a drug
that causes this kind of wood like this
isn't the answer there's there's some
something needs to be done but I don't
know how much uh like
part of the problem too is both my
parents were also like ill so it's just
like a family of Sickies luckily we're
not a family of Sickies anymore but like
so I can't I don't know what you would
do like yeah I was definitely depressed
I remember like not wanting people to at
school to know my brother would go I was
like don't say I have arthritis it's
like an old person disease yeah so don't
say that but I do think that the
physical like the anger and stuff I
don't I think that was Diet related I
think a lot of that was Diet related
given the fact that
I can get my body to come well I know
what my reaction to Foods is now yeah
and I get angry so yeah
yeah it's a cycle too right the anger is
going to increase the inflammation and
so the arthritis is gonna get worse and
so on and so forth you know
um
yeah pretty crazy so what's your plan
then yeah what what's your plan in the
future yeah what's your goal here uh I
mean I my goal is just to speak on this
topic as much as possible I would love
to see this book in medical schools and
also in a psychiatric residency
trainings
um yes that book may cause side effects
you know they use like the Bell jar
as an example of depression in in some
medical schools they use an on Quiet
Mind for
um bipolar issues not quite yeah or
schizophrenia I can't remember there's
some that's the thing there's so many
memoirs about psychiatric illnesses that
are used
as part of curriculums because it helps
practitioners understand what their
patients are going through but there's
nothing about withdrawal and so I think
that like we need we need that we need
that to be a part of the conversation so
for me as just as much knowledge as I
can get out there as possible
um I would also really really love to
see legislative legislative change and
requiring pharmaceutical companies to
provide more reasonable smaller jumps in
their in their drugs so like it
shouldn't be that you have to go from 75
milligrams of Effexor to 50 to 37.5 the
jumps are too big you should be able to
get much much smaller possibly even
custom dosages you can get custom
dosages through uh through compound
pharmacies but not everybody has access
to those so I would I would just really
like to see ironically more availability
um of lower dosages for these drugs and
smaller dosages so people can
help taper more effectively
that's something we should probably
mention too so one of the things we
figured out
um well one of the things I figured out
that you could do to taper off these
meds is use a compounding pharmacy so
you can like search them if you're in
cities it's a lot easier much easier but
you can have your doctor fax specific
prescriptions so if you're at like a
hundred you can go to 91 and they'll
compound the medication for you and give
it to you so if you have access to a
compounding pharmacy and you're trying
to get off of medications you can go
down 10 at a time or whatever your body
can tolerate using a compounding
pharmacy they're very helpful you do
have to pay extra and there isn't really
an alternative other than and and like
slicing pills like that it means you're
gonna go like up and down in doses which
is going to make the withdrawal worse
it's just yeah and you can't even
slightly like not all pills can be cut
because then you break the chemical
chains so it's really important that
you've got the knowledge of each
specific drug I mean some can be
dissolved in water some can't some you
can cut some can't some you can count
the beads out some you can't so it's
just very important to have the Deep
knowledge of that which I mean the
information is out there on the internet
I mean because it's had to be this has
been very much a patient-led revolution
and it's because enough people are
starting to make noise that we're
starting to sort of I think maybe see a
little change
very early on
yeah
I think so I think it's the same kind of
thing like people kind of know processed
foods aren't good in a in more of an
in-depth way than they knew 10 years ago
right like they knew what junk food was
but they're like oh no it's more than
that I think the same thing is probably
going to happen with
you know the more people talk about talk
about this plus what is it you'd
probably know this better than me but
isn't it 20 of people are on psych meds
it's like there's a bunch of different I
think it's like one in five
and so yeah that's two yeah twenty
percent and then I mean it also it's
really hard to get data in the us
because we don't have a centralized
system so you're not getting full
reports so the reports we do get are
like from
like insurance companies and all those
sorts of things there's more there's
more data from other countries I mean
even like
I mean in let's see in 2019 43 million
Americans were taking lexprozole after
another SSRI that's just SSRI Lexapro
that was the one that made me angry yeah
yeah
okay well Brooke
um where can people find you online or
find more information about your book so
I'm I'm Brook seam everywhere that's
b-r-o-o-k-e-s-i-e-m you can find me on
my website on Instagram
um I'm not particularly active on other
forms of social media but I do exist
there
um I also have a newsletter called
Happiness is a skill that talks a lot
about these sort of things and that's
just at learnhappy.substack.com
wherever books are sold Amazon audible
bookstores
UK Australia Canada everywhere
good good well thank you very much for
coming on thanks for writing your book
sorry you had to go through that but you
may help a lot of people so maybe the
suffering is worth it yeah in the end
same for you guys thanks so much for
sharing your story
[Music]